[Applause]
good morning it's Tuesday this is a
Brazilian soccer jersey signed by Pele
he wrote dftba on it it was given to me
by Brazilian nerdfighters at LeakyCon
who also gave me this book which
hundreds of them read and annotated Wow
by the way this sideways girl is really
pretty but speaking of LeakyCon I woke
up Saturday around 8 a.m. to one of the
best views in America's best city
Chicago I threw on a Hunger Games
t-shirt brushed my teeth four women from
America didn't walk down stairs to begin
my 2012 leakycon I chatted with that
Grossman in front of a lot of people and
then managed to destroy my phone by
dropping it from a height of
approximately 8 inches as shown in this
dramatic reenactment and I picked it up
and it was totally shattered then I went
to a massive nerdfighter gathering where
you and I discussed the edge lessness of
the universe and books belonging to
their readers and then there was a sword
fight from which I of course emerged
victorious and then I signed for several
hours with you and Lauren and Matt and
other people you can see less well
because this isn't my good camera then
Valerie and I took the stuff back to the
dftba booth and i signed posters for a
few hours i like signing my name and not
to brag or anything but I've gotten
really good at it so this was pretty fun
then I hung out with author friends
while Maureen Johnson stared at me and
that distinctly Maureen Johnson II way
of hers and then I attended a panel
called I was a teenage author in which I
had to read a story I wrote for my high
school literary journal Here I am
talking about an injured Firefly
really what do we do without a gun after
that I was feeling good and embarrassed
plus I was a little bit overwhelmed with
people and I needed a new phone so I
decided to walk to the Apple store but
first I walked across the street to
Grant Park the scene of my first wizard
rock concert back on 8 808 back when
YouTube was pixelated hey that was the
first day I discovered that people other
than me knew the words to your songs and
it was also when I begin to understand
how awesome nerdfighters and Harry
Potter fans are IRL although I could
never imagine that your shows would one
day look like this then I walked north
past segwaying tourists and the line for
the Art Institute and its famous lions
past a wish to be ordinary and kids
playing beneath the Tower of faces
across the Chicago River past a cafe
that seemed to willfully ignore the fact
that Rene Descartes died before coffee
was introduced to France through the
glut of tourists to the Apple Store
walking back with my new phone I
remembered I'd forgotten to visit the
beam where the first huge nerdfighter
gathering happened on 8 808 at 8:08 p.m.
when Amy Krauss Rosenthal began the
beckoning of lovely I love this
sculpture the way it reflects and
distorts ourselves and our world back to
us while also providing a good perch for
seagulls and I was thinking about the
four years and four days between then
and now feeling as Neutral Milk Hotel
once put it how strange it is to be
anything at all when suddenly a Dutch
nerdfighter and author named Buddy
approached me he was visiting the beam
because part of a book he liked Will
Grayson Will Grayson takes place there
and then he stumbled upon the co-author
of that book he gave me a copy of his
own book we exchanged dftba s and then
went our separate ways how improbable is
that Hank how improbable are we how
strange and how lovely it is to be
anything at all
Hank I'll see you on Friday actually
wave wave at the beam
that's awesome